so how long do you think we will have to
wait for three ideally two years okay
right because it's all shot 13. no no no
we got we got three is shot and the
first part of four is shot yes so I
think we're getting a big old green
light here from from the world saying we
want more of this I know some of the
casters told me they didn't give away
Secrets but they said a lot of new
interesting characters are being
introduced right I think people that we
will love to see the whole idea is to
give people what they want what they
expect but also do all kinds of swerves
and new stuff that they don't expect you
know how this goes you've been you know
you've been through award season before
I know it never gets old to you it
doesn't get old and it doesn't get not
scary yeah to be considered in the same
category in the same season with Steven
Spielberg is daunting yeah he and I are
Pals I just texted with him yesterday
and he said how do we find ourselves in
this in these situations he said he said
I'll be up I'll be at the party we can
talk there I'll be drinking ginger I
said I'm going to be drinking something
a lot stronger than Ginger trust me I
just want to say from the heart that to
me if Avatar does win it's a celebration
of Cinema coming back in full strength
in a year where that happened with Top
Gun and with wakanda forever and with
with Avatar you know we're back we're
going back to the movies and that's
important to me
[Music]